there is a man who has been around
foreign policy and statecraft for i
think 700 years at this point henry
kissinger henry kissinger was the
secretary of state for richard nixon
he's now i believe 99 years old he's got
his 18th or 19th book out
and
the book is worth paying attention to
because i don't i don't agree with henry
kissinger on everything but he's he's
really good on
on
real politique you know he's really good
on taking the kind of idealism and
platitudes out of foreign policy and
just talking in terms of cold hard
interests and henry kissinger believes
that we are on the brink of war in the
united states and the really bad news
here
beyond the fact that our young people
are not not in fighting form and i don't
think that america right now with
one of the worst economies we've ever
had in our nation's history and with
people who are not exactly patriotic and
with people who are physically not very
fit
the other problem is henry kissinger
believes we're on the brink of war not
just with one power but with two
kissinger believes that we are on the
brink of war with russia
and china and furthermore he agrees with
me that a lot of it is our fault not our
fault but the fault of our stupid
leaders right now head on over to
goodranchers.com
knowles regardless of what this
administration defines as a recession
americans are worried because we're in a
recession food and gas prices are higher
than i've ever seen in my lifetime that
is why i am so grateful for my favorite
meat delivery service good ranchers good
ranchers offers a recession proof
subscription model that lets you lock in
the price the day you subscribe so not
only is it recession proof it's
inflation-proof too it's absolutely a
ridiculous deal i have no idea how these
guys are going to stay in business
because they've got top quality meat
they're giving you ridiculously
affordable prices and you can lock it in
as inflation turns us all into zimbabwe
we're going to have you know
wheelbarrows full of trillion dollar
bills soon but you'll still have great
meet good ranchers is also currently
running a back to school give back
program with the goal of donating 100
000 high quality meals to children in
need to help out i am offering 10 lucky
listeners the chance to win 30 minutes
with me
via zoom on september 30th where you can
ask me anything we're calling it a meet
and greet get it go to
goodranchers.com use code knowles at
checkout you'll get 30 bucks off plus
free shipping you can subscribe to lock
in your price and recession slash
inflation proof your meals for life plus
you'll be automatically entered to win
30 minutes of all access with me
september 30th it's a meet and greet
this offer ends august 31st go to
goodranchers.com
use code knowles at checkout and maybe
i'll see you at the meet and greet
henry kissinger says we're on the brink
of war because our stupid leaders have
made a lot of bad decisions
i have been saying this for months now
and i have been smeared as a pro-putin
puppet and all sorts of dumb
left-wing slogans because of it but
henry kissinger says that i'm right
kissinger makes this point he says quote
americans resist separating the idea of
diplomacy from that of personal
relationships with the adversary they
tend to view negotiations he tells me in
missionary rather than psychological
terms seeking to convert or condemn
their interlocutors rather than to
penetrate their thinking
from the beginning of the war in ukraine
the approach that i've had to it is from
the perspective of what does putin want
why is he doing this what does he want
why does he think this benefits him
right now to do this
the libs and the swishes
have approached it from putin bad he's
the most bad man the baddest most bad
man ever and zielinski he's a good man
very much the good man and not bad man
you say okay maybe maybe all of that's
true i don't know but it's not going to
help you understand anything about the
war in ukraine it's not going to help
you understand how we got here certainly
not going to help you understand how we
get out
kissinger says we're at the edge of war
with russia and china on issues which we
partly created without any concept of
how this is going to end or what it's
supposed to lead to i said from the
beginning i said nato bears a lot of
responsibility here for creating a
provocative situation nato doesn't bear
moral responsibility for invading
ukraine obviously
depending on how you think of the maidan
revolution in 2014 but it's not as
though tanks are rolling in from the
west into ukraine that's not what they
bear responsibility for but they bear
nato and the united states leading it
bears some responsibility
for
misplaying
our hands that's what i said when i said
that what did i you're a pro
russia stooge puppet kisses you're
saying the same thing
he says we're at the brink of war
because of issues that we've partly
created
kissinger said that in cautious policies
on the part of the u.s and nato may have
touched off the crisis in ukraine he
sees no choice but to take vladimir
putin's stated security concerns
seriously and believes that it was a
mistake for nato to signal to ukraine
that it might eventually join the nato
alliance he said
i won't do a henry kissinger because you
want people to understand a word i say
he said i thought that poland all the
traditional western countries that have
been part of western history were
logical members of nato
but ukraine in his view is a collection
of territories
once appended to russia which russians
see as their own even though some
ukrainians do not stability would be
better served by its acting as a buffer
between russia and the west
he says i was in favor of the full
independence of ukraine but i thought
its best role was something like finland
this is exactly my perspective
on
russia and ukraine
border states
are good but rather buffer states are
good states between great powers and
rival powers it's good to have a little
buffer in between them that plays each
side off of the other one
doesn't make you a putin stooge doesn't
make you a terror anti-american or
anything like that the people who were
urging caution on nato expansion after
the fall of the berlin wall were george
kennan daniel patrick moynihan sam young
really mainstream people
somewhat liberal people actually and
they were cold warriors who were really
tough on the soviet union in the cold
war but they realized that our foreign
policy has been really really stupid
and you're seeing this right now even
with the fbi even on the domestic front
you are seeing
bad political actors let their emotions
get away with them and destroy
hard one peace
and hard-won stability in our country
because they want to get trump they hate
trump so much
and we've got it we've got to get putin
and we've got to antagonize putin and
we've got to go this guy and get the
other guy and they're not thinking
strategically they're not thinking from
the perspective of what is best for
americans
i'm so glad you liked that clip you know
we hit 1 million subscribers and that's
great i feel fabulous that we are now in
the top youtube channels out there but i
want to go a little further i want a
billion okay the only way we're going to
get a billion you got a ring ding dong
slash smack like and subscribe hit the
bell whatever get the notifications
subscribe to the michael knowles show
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you